we've had an incredible 24 hours in the
United States I want to start today with
huge news out of Minneapolis where the
other three officers as they are known
involved in the death of George Floyd
have now been charged and the charges
against Derek shavon have been upgraded
from third-degree murder to
second-degree murder a lot to discuss so
starting off with reminder Derek shavon
is the officer in the viral video that
spurred the national and even global
protests the officer putting his knee to
George Floyd's neck for many minutes
before George Florida ultimately died
the three officers visible in the video
sort of standing around as this happens
have now been charged with aiding and
abetting second-degree murder and aiding
and abetting second-degree manslaughter
second-degree murder and aiding and
abetting second-degree murder punishable
by up to 40 years in prison
manslaughter aiding and abetting
manslaughter punishable by up to 10
years in prison now let's talk about the
Derek shovin charges and this is there's
a lot of detail here that's important
the original charges against Derek
shavon were third degree murder and
second degree manslaughter the murder
charge has now been upgraded to
second-degree murder this is very
important because second-degree murder
carries with it number one a much more
serious potential sentence but also
number two potentially a more difficult
to prove case for the prosecution in a
sense sort of maybe except that the
third degree murder charges when you
look at the statute also may not have
been the right ones for the situation so
but again we've got to look at what the
statutes say in Minnesota a third degree
murder charge is defined as quote
whoever without intent to effect the
death of any person meaning without
deliberately trying to kill someone
causes the death of another by
perpetrating and act eminently dangerous
to others and evincing a depraved mind
not
or evincing a depraved mind and evincing
a depraved mind without regard for human
life is guilty of murder in the third
degree so this is from the 2019
Minnesota Statutes and what shavon did
would be very tough to prove in a court
of law
as what's called a depraved mind murder
so you can make the case not that the
charge should be second degree versus
third degree based on the severity so to
speak of what Derek shavon is accused of
doing
but because the third degree murder
statute includes this depraved mind
component so instead we have second
degree murder here there are two types
of second-degree murder in Minnesota
Statutes intentional and unintentional
if shawhans restraint of George Floyd
caused Floyd's death he could be guilty
of unintentional second-degree murder
even if he was not trying to kill George
Floyd it would be very difficult to
prove in a court of law based on what
we've seen that shavon was trying to
kill George Floyd it seems as though
unintentional second-degree murder is
the statute under which George Floyd's
death would fall from the perspective of
Derek shawhans actions now there's one
more analysis here about this that's
less about what you can prove but more
about what shavon is likely to plead
down to so let me kind of frame this up
for you in a different way if this goes
to trial I think it's going to be tough
but not impossible to get a guilty
verdict against Derek shavon that has
nothing to do with my opinion about what
went down it is merely my understanding
of how these trials often work and what
the law is so bear with me here we have
two autopsies that were done of George
Floyd so far that I've read in one of
those autopsies the cause of death is
not alone the actions of Derek shavon
the cause of death says it was not
asphyxiation by Derek shavon and it was
at the wrists
rent used by Derrick shavon combined
with pre-existing medical conditions and
possible intoxication now you and I may
think that that's BS and indeed there's
a second autopsy which says something
very different which says that the death
was indeed caused by asphyxiation as a
result of Derrick shawhans actions but
my point is if this goes to trial a good
defense attorney which Derrick shavon
will certainly have is very much able to
introduce reasonable doubt about whether
shawhans actions definitely are the
cause of George Floyd's death by
focusing on the one autopsy that says
you know there were pre-existing medical
conditions that were a factor possible
intoxication and restraint you bring in
some medical examiner that they'll find
and say doctor whoever given this
autopsy is it possible that absent
George Floyd's medical conditions and
possible intoxication that he could have
survived the way that he was restrained
by Derrick shavon
yes counsel that's possible so you and I
both understand that this is apparently
BS but you would then have a fight a
legal fight where the defense is
introducing doubt and the prosecution is
saying well we have a different autopsy
this OP topsy does say that George Floyd
was asphyxiated by Derrick shavon but it
becomes a fight and remember you only
need reasonable doubt to acquit the
standard of evidence in a civil trial
may well be a preponderance of evidence
does it seem like 51% of the evidence
points to Derrick shawhans
responsibility in a criminal trial you
need only introduce reasonable doubt so
this gets me back to the reason for
moving from third degree murder to
second degree murder is the idea that
you go to a second-degree murder charge
because it carries a higher penalty so
that you increase the desire from
Derrick shavon to plead to something
smaller to avoid a trial altogether
which may or may not go well for the
prosecution that's another possibility
as to why you would have seen an
elevated charge from third degree murder
to second degree murder
needless to say it is correct
to elevate the charge the second-degree
murder based on our reading of the
Minnesota statutes and it is a good
thing that the other officers have been
charged and all were brought in
yesterday this is going to be this is
going to be a very long thing it in by
every indication this will not be
resolved for far longer than the current
protests are likely to go so we've got
to really buckle in and realize that
this is going to be a long process
speedy trial okay it is still going to
be a long and protracted process okay
this is incredibly important in
maintaining an accurate understanding of
this week's protests despite claims from
Trump and his press secretary and a ton
of different right-wingers that Auntie
fuh was doing all sorts of violence in
Washington DC at the protests this week
the FBI has found no evidence that an
Tifa was involved in the Washington DC
violence on Sunday that's the day that
the protests sort of had peak violence
or unrest they've become more and more
peaceful throughout the week now the
reason this matters is that one of the
ways that the Trump administration has
waged a propaganda war against the
overwhelmingly peaceful protesters is by
making them seem co-opted by an Tifa and
overwhelmingly violent Trump of course
even tweeting on Sunday night quote the
United States of America will be
designating an Tifa as a terrorist
organization we already talked on Monday
about the legal reality and
constitutionality of Trump doing that I
don't want to rehash that today but it
actually doesn't matter because it was a
political tool which was followed up on
on Monday with Trump saying I may send
the US military to States against
governor's wishes to further repress the
protesters who he is insisting are
overwhelmingly violent lawbreakers now
if you believe the protesters are more
violent than they are you are more
likely to support Trump's idea of
sending in the military if you believe
that violent and Tifa which again
remember there's no there's no real
thing and Tifa is more of a strategy and
an umbrella term than an or
organization if you believe violent and
Tifa is a predominant factor at these
protests you're more likely to look the
other way at repression of protesters by
police well we now have documents from
the Washington FBI field office which
say very clearly as of 5:00 p.m.
based on CHS canvassing open source and
social media partner engagement and
liaison FBI Washington field office has
no intelligence indicating involvement
or presence of an Tifa now I want to be
really really really really clear here
this is one location on one day it was
claimed that an Tifa were all over DC
the FBI found that they were not this
doesn't mean that there was no auntie
for presence anywhere clearly there was
some presence of whatever we are
defining as an Tifa the issue with all
of this is that an Tifa itself is first
of all tiny and secondly it's completely
sparse in its organization and I want to
make really crystal clear before I start
getting you the the you know the emails
and the tweets and all of it I am not
telling you that I am supportive of
auntie FFA's tactics I'm not denying
that people operating under the general
banner event if I have done violence in
the past of course they have I'm not
aware of an Tifa ever killing anybody
but there has been violence done by
people sort of purporting to be under
the umbrella of aunt Eva and I am
against that the point is number one and
Tifa is more of an idea and a strategy
than it is an organization where we can
say the KKK was present here okay well
that's a much more defined group there
is a leadership structure there is
membership there are meetings bla bla
bla that is not the case with auntie feh
and that's why this is all fundamentally
a distraction the protests are mostly
peaceful have there been bad actors of
course there have looters have looted
while protesters have protested the
point is whether or not they subscribe
to the general umbrella term of auntie
feh it lacks all organization and it
doesn't change that the bad actors are
incredibly small in
whether the non-peaceful protestors are
or aren't an Tifa is actually irrelevant
here because an Tifa is not an
organization with an established
structure leadership or the like it's a
way to justify using force against
protesters it's a way to justify Trump
sending in the troops literally and it's
a way to disqualify the activism
concerns of the protesters Tuesday night
we did a livestream looking at protests
in I'm trying to think now Boston New
York City Denver DC Atlanta Los Angeles
Columbus Ohio there were a couple other
places I don't remember exactly there
was no violence anywhere during the
two-hour stream where we were just
watching protests in all of these places
with the exception of about five minutes
in Atlanta where protesters destroyed
you know those chain-link fences that go
around a construction site some of that
fencing was destroyed and there were
even claims that the reason that
happened is because police were
releasing tear gas and protesters had to
in order to get away from it rip down
some of that fencing that may be true or
not doesn't make it okay but the point
is we had to spend two hours to find
five minutes across eight or ten cities
of something that was short of peaceful
protesting the reason this is being done
is that Trump can't lead any other way I
told you on Monday Tuesday he doesn't
have any other tools other than
criticized the people getting the media
attention and think about how can you
deploy more shows a force later in the
program I'm going to talk to you about
Donald Trump again obsessed with tanks
starting to ask the Pentagon questions
about what sort of tanks could we deploy
as a show of force along with the
military Pentagon appears to be turning
against Trump Trump's former Secretary
of Defense Jim mattis denouncing Trump
and we're going to get to all of that
later these are really fluid dynamics in
terms of the relationships between
institutions of power where even the
Pentagon and Department of Defense not
organizations that I find to be the
epitome of altruism not organizations
where I say you can always trust the
Department of Defense even they are
saying what Trump wants is too much
remember to follow me on twitter at D
Pakman and a quick reminder if you
regularly just consume a clip here or
there on IG TV or YouTube or Facebook we
have a daily audio podcast and I know a
lot of you prefer audio podcasts
long-form - short video clips we have a
free audio podcast you can find on
itunes stitcher spotify google play
podcasts etc make sure you're subscribed
to that for the daily show let me know
what you think about the latest with the
protests on twitter at pakman and we'll
be right back the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world's famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are Peggy cool
and Mary core mansik to fallow I hope I
pronounced that correctly thank you so
much for your support also LaRue Brown
is today's longtime sustaining member of
the day Laura's been a member for almost
5 years support us directly no middlemen
no intermediaries by signing up at join
pakman.com ok everything on fox news is
narrative journalism and they've been
caught badly and obviously editing video
to remove police with guns drawn who
work handcuffing the innocent good
samaritan black people at one of this
week's protests and understand that
there's a contingent that wants to put
together a very specific narrative about
the protests and that narrative is the
protesters are overwhelmingly bad and
violent they're insincere in their
activism priorities the police are good
and trump is very good and leading the
country properly
now of course there's lots of different
details that make the reality a lot more
complex protesters are mostly good and
police are mostly good but a lot of this
is about systems of power there's the
issue of Trump's leadership
constitutional issues with the military
there's endless issues here but what I
want to focus in on in this segment is
FoxNews distorting the truth in in just
a really specific way and as Rolling
Stone reports there's a local Fox
affiliate that ran a story about a
family flagging down law enforcement
to protect the business from looters
when police show up the officers
handcuffed the people who were legally
holding firearms and trying to defend
this business and fox news when they
rebroadcast this story they removed the
entire part of the story where police
drew their guns and put the Good
Samaritan black gun owners in handcuffs
so the local Fox affiliate Fox eleven
included all of that because they were
broadcasting it live you actually see
the police manhandling the victims
pulling a woman out of a car who had
nothing to do with the entire thing they
handcuffed the people who called the
cops now I can't play that for you
because local Fox stations are super
aggressive in their copyright claims and
they'll penalize my channel for doing it
but here's the the later clip from Fox
News where they remove that altogether
the police showing up and harassing and
handcuffing the victims was casually
completely removed take a look it
happened yesterday in Van Nuys as well
where owners of a liquor store were
protecting it with their long firearms
when about a half a dozen looters showed
up and tried to hit a golden jewelry
store next door there was a standoff and
there the reporter became a witness
three vehicles drove up in front of the
buy gold and they told him get away from
that and they started arguing about it
and after they started arguing about it
that's when we started flagging you down
so they were able to stop that from
taking place I think one or two of the
looters were detained now the there's
two protests going on right now in
Hollywood what a completely sanitized
and dishonest version of what happened
liquor store defenders with legal guns
who happen to be black defend the store
until the police show up and the full
story of course is that police showed up
aimed the guns at the people defending
the store as well as peaceful bystanders
and even handcuffed some of them this is
Fox News going as Rolling Stone says out
it's way to selectively edit the scene
and make the police appear to be nothing
but helpful and ignore the fact that the
police showed up cuffed the black people
with guns first and ask questions later
now in the video that went out live on
FOX 11 which I encourage you to check
out you can actually hear the reporter
that was on scene yelling at the police
saying these are the good guys no these
are not the looters these are the good
guys
you're cuffing the good guys and she's
insisting and the police tell her you've
got to calm down it's one of the most
chaotic insane videos that I've seen and
you know actually it's so important
really that you see this let's just play
the Fox 11 video will probably get
flagged or whatever but we can't really
tell the story here is the insane video
from Fox 11 live where you actually see
all the craziness go down and you hear
the reporter yelling at the cops these
aren't the bad guys all right now oh my
god all three of them okay we're putting
those in handcuffs right now we're
protecting this baby where's the loot
ergo description black white
african-americans dare to show you how
easily and quickly things can go wrong
or can be misinterpreted
Wow Messina this is one of the wildest
things I've ever seen and then to see
that taking the woman from the car she's
not involved she just stopped to look
they actually take a random woman out of
her car cuff and detain the Good
Samaritans it is completely bonkers so
there's two parts here there's the story
of police showing up and assuming that
the Good Samaritans with the legal guns
are actually the bad guys now we can
debate is it about race is it
five-percent about race is it 50% of
yeah that's one part of it then you have
the Fox News disinformation propaganda
piece of it which is that the Good
Samaritans were detained on live TV and
Fox News national has just removed that
completely from their telling of the
story and doesn't even mention it and
this contributes to the overall
narrative that Fox News has been
perpetuating the protesters are the bad
guys and they must be stopped the police
are never the problem and sometimes the
police are even actually the victims
according to some of the presentations
that are made incredible incredible
story incredible situation imagine being
that exasperated Fox 11 reporter who
sees it all go down and then sees the
police cuff the good guys yelling these
these are these aren't the looters these
are the calm down ma'am calm down excuse
us while we pull a random woman out of
her car for stopping to see what's going
on sick and this is just one little
story about so many things
how context matters preconceived notions
selective news editing how these out of
context 40 second stories on news
channels often fail to really tell us
what's going on many lessons to be
learned here and it's also just another
one of these unbelievable videos that
you have to see to believe that this is
what's going on
Donald Trump is increasingly at odds
with America in terms of the protests
and Donald Trump is increasingly at odds
with his own officials will talk about
the America part a little bit later but
let's start here as you know Donald
Trump has been considering
the insurrection Act of 1807 to send US
military to States to quell protests and
in fact there were some troops deployed
yesterday but reportedly they were very
quickly called back by the Pentagon
still early reporting on that but there
seems to be a conflict brewing between
Donald Trump and the Pentagon there now
this barely warrants repeating for you
guys but I will repeat it anyway the
protests are mostly peaceful they are
also increasingly peaceful with every
passing day we see protesters policing
themselves more and more rooting out
people who want to cause trouble and
that's a very good thing to see well
Donald Trump is thinking about could we
maybe send tanks to the streets to
intimidate people and the Pentagon to
their credit seems to be not having it
Secretary of Defense mark Esper has
increasingly distanced himself from
Trump's ideas on this we don't know
whether Esper will be fired within 48
hours that may well be but over the last
two days mark espera has been saying you
know my comments on Monday and Tuesday
they were mostly just general shows of
support for Donald Trump you know
telling governor's request military aid
if you need it but Esper reportedly
didn't really think Trump was going to
act on militarizing the streets against
governor's demands this is a huge
mistake by mark s / mark s /
underestimated the erratic and dangerous
nature of donald trump's out-of-control
authoritarianism what we are learning
and what every Trump official should
know by now is that it's very dangerous
to placate donald trump with the yes mr.
president the military yes sir mr.
president of course because now Trump is
actually asking hey what kind of tanks
could we maybe send to the streets of
America according to what a pentagon
official told The Daily Beast and the
Pentagon listen the Pentagon is not the
good guy in the history of American
politics and geopolitics there's no
doubt about that but the Pentagon seems
to be making it clear they're not
looking to send in the military and
they're not looking to send in tanks and
once again I would not be shocked if
Secretary of Defense Mark asper was
fired within the next couple of days
I said this earlier and it bears
repeating this is not a rehearsal Donald
Trump is not distinguishing between
protesters and looters Donald Trump had
protesters smoked out to clear a path so
that he could take a picture with a
Bible in front of a church a few days
ago and I want to point out something
else
a lot of either ignorant people or bad
faith actors you can never really tell
with some of these people they are
trying to conflate the State National
Guard with Trump sending in federal
troops and I really want to make clear
that there's a big difference here
National Guard's are run by States
governors for example a couple months
ago brought out their respective state
National Guard's for coronavirus related
help they've also brought out their
state national guards around the
protests that is completely different
than the president saying I don't agree
with how governors are handling this I'm
going to deploy US military to States
against the wishes of governors by
utilizing the insurrection Act of 1807
that is a completely insidious
authoritarian threat the state governor
saying we just need support from our
state National Guard
that's how it's supposed to work that
states rights and we shouldn't conflate
it we can still be against the
deployment of state national guards but
don't allow yourself to be tricked into
thinking if a state is deploying the
National Guard there's really no
difference with Trump sending in the
troops it is very very different now as
far as Donald Trump and his tanks Trump
has been desperate for tanks rolling on
American streets since he became
president of the United States remember
for a while he wanted a parade with
tanks he wanted it to happen for
propaganda reasons now Trump once tanks
out there to repress protesters
he just wants tanks out there at his
say-so that's really what it comes to he
wants I don't know if it's his own
version of version of Tiananmen Square
or if Trump believes that the strength
that will be portrayed by tanks rolling
at his say-so will reflect positively on
him I don't know exactly what Trump is
thinking but
this is all authoritarian dystopia
protests repress them with the military
tanks roll them down American streets
and by by the way I mean this is like so
minor given what's going on
rolling tanks down American streets is
extremely damaging to the streets to the
roads in a physical sense I don't know
if Trump knows that but tanks are not
meant to be rolling down American
streets or better said streets are not
meant to handle the weight and
characteristics of tanks and you know
what who's going to repair that is Trump
going to pay for that Trump keeps
talking about doing infrastructure
spending and we're still not doing it
just like a minor coda to the broader
story that we're dealing with here we're
gonna have more on this a lot more in
fact on the David Pakman show Instagram
page david pakman show make sure you're
following us there coming up next
Trump's former Secretary of Defense Jim
mattis denounces Trump calls him a
threat to the Constitution and Trump
responds predictably let me put it that
way we'll talk about that next the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him welcome back to the
David Pakman show this is one of the
biggest stories this week and it is
fascinating Donald Trump's former
Secretary of Defense Jim mattis has
completely denounced and condemned
Donald Trump and predictably Donald
Trump went completely off the deep end
exploding in an unhinged tirade last
night it's truly something and I'm not
aware of any time in history that a
Secretary of Defense has denounced the
president they served so brutally and
soaked so completely and so so
wholeheartedly I asked for other
examples yesterday on Twitter was not
given any now I want to be clear I'm not
any particular fan of Jim mattis I'm not
you know I wasn't a big fan of Trump's
former Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
but it can't be denied that they were
two of the calmer voices in Trump's
administration who were even remotely
connected to reality now since leaving
his position as Secretary of Defense Jim
mattis hasn't said very much about
Donald Trump and he even said I think it
was about a year ago or so roughly that
he doesn't really plan or think it's
appropriate I'm summarizing here to
criticize the sitting president the
president they work for clearly that has
changed and Jim mattis has now denounced
Trump and accused him of ordering the
military to violate the constitutional
rights of Americans understand that the
former Trump's own former Secretary of
Defense is accusing Trump of trying to
violate the constitutional rights of
Americans let's look at some of mattis's
letter then we will get trump's
explosive and completely predictable
reaction mattis wrote I have watched
this week's unfolding a
Vence angry and appalled the words equal
justice under law are carved in the
pediment of the United States Supreme
Court this is precisely precisely what
protesters are rightly demanding it is a
wholesome and unifying demand one that
all of us should be able to get behind
we must not be distracted by a small
number of lawbreakers the protests are
defined by tens of thousands of people
of conscience who are insisting that we
live up to our values our values as
people and our values as a nation we
must reject and hold accountable those
in office who would make a mockery of
our Constitution then Jim mattis goes on
to say in this letter
absolutely brutally that quote Donald
Trump is the first president in my
lifetime who does not try to unite the
American people does not even pretend to
try instead he tries to divide us we are
witnessing the consequences of three
years of this deliberate effort we are
witnessing the consequences of three
years without mature leadership we can
unite without him drawing on the
strength and harun in our civil society
this will not be easy as the past few
days have shown but we owe it to our
fellow citizens to pass generations that
bled to defend our promise and to our
children then madis who if nothing else
he chooses his words carefully actually
references Nazis saying quote
instructions given by the military
departments to our troops before the
Normandy invasion reminded soldiers that
the Nazi slogan for destroying us was
divide and conquer our American answer
is in Union there is strength we must
summon that unity to surmount this
crisis confident that we are better than
our politics and then lastly talking
about the Constitution which like him or
not and I'm no big mattis fan he
genuinely does seem to care about the
Constitution regardless of who it is
that is in power saying quote when I
joined the military some fifty years ago
I swore an oath to support and defend
the Constitution never did I dream that
troops taking that same oath would be
ordered under any circumstance to
violate the
to tional rights of their fellow
citizens much less to provide a bizarre
photo-op for the elected
commander-in-chief with military
leadership standing alongside
referencing of course that horrifying
photo-op earlier this week where Donald
Trump gassed protests had protesters
gassed he didn't do it himself to clear
a path to his Bible photo-op in front of
st. John's Church I am not aware of such
a brutal takedown of a president by
their own former Secretary of Defense if
you have an example I am more than
willing to see it now Trump's reaction
you have to see Trump's reaction when
the maddest letter was published
yesterday I was just waiting for Trump
to go completely crazy it took a couple
of hours but he eventually did tweeting
quote probably the only thing Barack
Obama and I have in common is that we
both had the honor of firing Jim mattis
the world's most overrated general I
asked for his letter of resignation and
felt great about it his nickname was
chaos which I didn't like and changed to
Mad Dog his primary strength was not
military but rather personal public
public relations I gave him a new life
things to do in battles to win but he
seldom brought home the bacon I didn't
like his leadership style or much else
about him and many others agree glad he
is gone now what's really amazing about
Trump's response is that you know
Trump's furious you can see his anger
Trump is seething that his own former
Secretary of Defense brutally has
condemned him but he can't really come
up with much to criticize Jim mattis
with he's an overrated general that
Trump said that so many times it's a
milquetoast insult I didn't like his
nickname so I changed it who cares he
was better at PR than military stuff
that speaks more about trumps poor
judgment of who to hire right Trump ran
on I will hire the best people how if
this is true if Matt mattis is better at
PR than military stuff how did Trump
stupidly hire them to run the Secretary
of Defense you don't have to like mattis
I am no Big Jim mattis fan but if you
say whose values do
I prefer guiding the country Trump's
which are mimimi or mattis's which at
least are ostensibly the Constitution
and an appropriate interpretation of it
I pick mattis over Trump every time now
one more thing mattis seems to have the
goods on Trump by all estimates if Jim
mattis wanted to he could actually
reveal things about Trump that may be
worse than anything we've seen yesterday
when the maddest letter came out New
York Times magazines Robert Draper
tweeted quote mattis is still holding
back though he's privately told friends
that Trump's behavior is far worse than
the reports and that the Republic is on
shaky footing he knows so much more than
he's currently divulging the reporting
is a [ __ ] a horror story so if the
truth is worse than the reporting as Jim
mattis reportedly said imagine what we
don't know imagine what we might know in
four weeks as Donald Trump continues to
unravel part of that unraveling appears
to be Trump's campaign looking at the
2020 map and panicking and that's what I
want to talk about next okay so we've
got national polls and state polls and
we have an electoral college system in
the United States doesn't matter if you
win the popular vote in the sense that
you can win the popular vote and lose
the election as Hillary Clinton did in
2016 you can also lose the popular vote
and win the election as Donald Trump did
in 2016 well the Trump campaign is
looking at the 2020 electoral map and
they're panicking because what they see
is really not good now I want to give
mine so this is getting really
interesting and I want to dig into the
data but I do feel the need to remind
everybody a lot can change in five
months just because this is where things
are today does not mean that this is
where things will be in five months
Trump could end up winning this
reelection in a huge landslide we all
need to vote etc okay now there are only
so many paths to victory for any one
candidate the paths to victory are a
little bit different
electoral II for Democrats than they are
for Republicans in our electoral college
system only some states are in place so
in November California and Massachusetts
are going to vote for Joe
North and South Dakota and Wyoming are
going to vote for Donald Trump and once
you start kind of crossing off the blue
states that will definitely go by and
the red states that will definitely go
for Trump you start to get a set of what
we call battleground states that are the
state's more likely to make a difference
in the election so Massachusetts has a
very small chance of being the decider
between Trump and Biden it's going to go
to Biden and it is not going to be the
state that influences who gets to 270
electoral votes there are states that
Trump carried easily in 2016 where he is
not doing so well and this presents a
real problem for Trump in his path to
270 electoral votes Arizona is a state
Trump won in 2016 where he's not doing
well right now Georgia is almost certain
to still go to Donald Trump but Trump is
actually having to spend some money in
Georgia a state that Republicans often
don't have to spend money in we've had
these national polls where Trump is
losing to Biden by 6 7 even 11 in the
latest Monmouth poll Monmouth poll very
highly rated by fivethirtyeight.com but
again the national picture is one thing
to get a real sense you have to look
state-by-state so check out some of
these examples in 2016 Trump won Arizona
by three and a half Biden's up by almost
three that's a six and a half point
swing against Trump in Arizona Florida
Trump won by 1.2 percent in 2016 Biden
is currently leading by 3.4 that's
almost a 5 point swing in Florida very
important state in Iowa
Trump won by almost 10 and he's up by
under 5 that's a 5 point swing against
Trump in Iowa Ohio massively important
to Republicans I'll explain why in a
moment
Trump won by 8 in 2016 Biden is
currently leading by 1 and Wisconsin
which was one of that treat one of the
the the trio of states that handed the
victory to Trump that were reasonable
states that Hillary Clinton could have
won Trump won Wisconsin by half a point
last election Biden currently winning by
three point four so Florida and Ohio are
massively important because they have a
ton of electoral votes and because they
are often the states that when a
Republican loses them they end up losing
the election so five-point swing in
Florida nine-point swing in Ohio away
from Donald Trump and here's why it
matters go to 270 to win calm and start
with the 2016 map it is really difficult
for Trump to have a path to victory
without Ohio
if only Ohio and Florida flipped a Biden
Biden wins and it's over doesn't matter
what happens in other states if Trump
keeps Florida but loses Ohio Biden can
still win by flipping Arizona and
Wisconsin where he's leading Wisconsin
and Michigan where he's leading or
Michigan and Arizona where he's leading
even just Pennsylvania in addition to
getting Ohio loses it for Donald Trump
this is why Ohio is so important for
Donald Trump and has been important for
Republican presidents in general never
mind
some of these other states now at the
tail end of this even if Trump keeps
Ohio in Florida which he's currently
losing but imagine that Ohio and Florida
go back to Donald Trump and he wins them
in November
Biden can still win by flipping
Wisconsin Michigan and Pennsylvania all
of which looked pretty good for him
right now or Pennsylvania Michigan and
Arizona you get the idea
holding every 2016 state is very
important for Trump he really can't
afford to lose very much you can go to
270 to win calm right now run the
combinations yourself now meanwhile
Trump's disapproval rating has hit a
six-month high dating all the way back
to November small moves but still
significant to some degrees so here's
what this means absolutely nothing in
terms of whether you should vote in
November we've got to keep up the
pressure Donald Trump here's I think the
most important point I want to make what
Donald Trump has done up until now
should already preclude him from being
reelected
you know if Trump cures cancer and
eliminates poverty in the next five
months come talk to me and then you know
maybe we'll have a different perspective
from what has already happened Donald
Trump deserves to be removed now we have
five
months during which we need to keep the
pressure up if the poles remain as they
are Trump will lose and we will remove
what what may be one of the gravest
national electoral errors in the history
of this country
if the pressure lets up the economy
starts to sort of look like it might be
in recovery it's conceivable that Donald
Trump will get himself reelected and so
this is a snapshot today we need to
continue and we need to keep it up make
sure you are following the show on
facebook at facebook.com slash david
pakman show we have been live-streaming
on Facebook as well I'll see you there
or in just two minutes on the other side
of this break the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
in the midst of some of the worst civil
unrest that we've seen in this country
for a long time coming at the juncture
of a hundred year pandemic police
killings of black men that have
generated massive protests a huge
economic recession Donald Trump is now
bragging he has been the best president
for black people since Abraham Lincoln
Trump tweeting this week quote my
administration has done more for the
black community than any president since
Abraham Lincoln passed Opportunity Zones
which with senator Tim Scott guaranteed
funding for HBCUs school choice past
criminal justice reform lowest black
unemployment poverty and crime rates in
history and then adding in a second
tweet in all caps and the best is yet to
come so let's pretend that this is
serious and this is a serious person
making a serious claim the first
question is does this even pass the
sniff test does it pass the test that
tunc Trump has done more for the black
community than any president dating all
the way back to Abraham Lincoln it
doesn't sound right and obviously it's
not right and Trump's persistent dog
whistles to white nationalists are only
a tiny tiny piece of it but let's pick
one of those things and actually think
about it in a little bit more detail so
one of the claims that Trump regularly
made before 25% of the workforce lost
their jobs because a corona virus was
that black unemployment is at record
lows and that Trump is of course to
thank for that
a couple things what you need to
understand is that when unemployment is
very low it's typically low for every
group so we no doubt had a very low
unemployment rate up until the corona
virus pandemic started when we talked
about the economy leading up to the
pandemic I made no effort to deceive or
hide the fact that we had a low
unemployment rate it was very low for
white people it was low for black people
it was you don't low for young and old
people it was low for men and women it
was low for college graduates and non
college graduates so thinking back to my
interview earlier this week with
Jonathan Faber about critical thinking
was black unemployment low because of
something Trump did was black
unemployment low and it applied to all
groups because of something Trump did or
was this part of the sort of natural
cycle of the economy what we know is job
growth certainly slowed from the pace
under Barack Obama but again only some
of this has to do with the president so
the logical question to ask would be
what specifically did Donald Trump do
that disproportionately created jobs for
black Americans relative to non black
Americans and when you actually boil it
down and think about it in this way
Trump didn't do anything
there was nothing now I'm gonna give you
one other example of this remember
during Barack Obama's presidency the
right would regularly say a record
number of people aren't working a record
number of people are outside of the
labor force and then Trump is
inaugurated and instantly up until three
months ago some of those same people
were saying a record number of people
are working now and it didn't sound
right how is it that we went from record
numbers of people not working under
Obama to record numbers of people
working under Donald Trump doesn't
really make sense well the truth is
during Obama's presidency a record
number of people were working and a
record number of people were not working
likewise during Trump's presidency
before coronavirus of course a record
number of people were working and a
record number of people we're not
working how is this possible the answer
is the population keeps growing if at
any given time roughly 55 percent of the
population is in the workforce and 45
percent of the population is out of the
workforce as long as our population
keeps growing you will simultaneously
continue to have more people working
than ever before and more people not
working than ever before the devil is in
the details why are people not working
is it because they don't have to because
the economy is doing really well is it
because there are no jobs is it
because there's been a population shift
to more older folks who are retirement
age or a population shift to a lot of
more college aged people who when they
are not working even if you're in
college full time you count as being out
of the labor force how much are people
earning are their wages allowing them to
afford the cost of living wherever it is
that they live so as you can very
quickly see for a long time we've had a
record number of people working and a
record number of people not working
coronavirus of course has changed that
but the question is is Trump doing more
for black people than anyone since
Abraham Lincoln that is obviously untrue
and it's something that only a
pathological pathological liar or
completely delusional person would say
they live for the sake of lying
they are hyperbolic in their lies and
that's all that this is and let's not be
confused about it you all know that I
always say don't dfi politicians these
are just people they are flawed people
sometimes they want to do things we
agree with sometimes they don't but the
idea of holding politicians up and I
don't care if it's the mag a crowd or
Bernie or bust or the Tulsi people or
whoever I don't recommend deifying any
politician but that doesn't mean that
there can be real material important
differences between one politician and
another and the civil unrest and
protests that we've been seeing this
week are providing a really good case
study to look at some of the differences
Donald Trump sat at the White House
tweeting threatening to deploy the
military to States and on one day this
week used police to gas protesters and
used horses to disperse protesters so
that he could walk over to st. John's
and get a picture awkwardly holding a
Bible that's what Trump did meanwhile
Joe Biden and Nancy Pelosi and Elizabeth
Warren have actually gone and met with
protesters and talked to protesters and
even marched with protesters in some
cases this doesn't make them perfect
people
it doesn't make Democrats uber
progressive it doesn't make them gods it
doesn't do anything other than show us
there is a really stark contrast right
now in terms of how completely out of
his element and in
Donald Trump is how unable to lead the
president is that he can't even do the
simple things that many elected
officials are doing yesterday Nancy
Pelosi as we are showing you on video
went out to the protests in Washington
DC spoke to protesters walked around was
part of what was going on doesn't mean
anything in particular about Nancy
Pelosi's policy positions but it does
tell us that she's at least out there
seeing what's going on and talking to
people
does this make Nancy Pelosi some
progressive change maker no she's a
moderately left establishment Democrat
but Trump is hiding out and tweeting
okay it's the contrast that matters
yesterday I told you about Democratic
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
she went out to participate in a march
on the streets in Washington DC brought
her husband along brought her dog along
we're showing our video audience some
video of that right now and again making
it very clear she was asked why is Trump
sending up the military she said well
because he's wrong joining protesters
talking to people being out there being
part of our community rather than
someone sitting at the White House in
the Oval Office or even you know in a
bunker as Donald Trump did did briefly
on Friday sending out tweets and
mobilizing forces and putting up fence
after fence after fence says I don't
know if you saw but significant new
fencing being erected around the White
House area
likewise Democratic presidential
candidate Joe Biden going out even
earlier than Nancy Pelosi even earlier
than Elizabeth Warren to talk to
protestors to understand what's going on
making a speech about the systemic
elements that are at play in what these
protests are meant to illuminate and and
and a deal with Biden Pelosi and Warren
do not deserve our support just because
they met with protesters we still need
to be thinking critically about every
single one of these individuals and who
we vote for but the point is there's an
absolute total minimum as public
officials that should be done just to
show you're even remotely engaged with
what's going on out there it is about
contrast with Donald Trump Trump stayed
at the White House and tweeted insults
he went to his bunker he walked over to
a church and held up a Bible that Ivanka
Trump care
over for him in a $1,500 purse for a
photo op after protesters were dispersed
with smoke and huge horses there's just
no comparison in terms of how unfit to
lead the president is this is just the
latest latest example now let's deal
with some of the critiques many of you
might no doubt say okay Biden Warren and
Pelosi they went out there but what have
they actually done and that's a fair
question
Biden's not even in an elected position
right now so what can he do other than
say here's what I would do as president
but they are actually there they're in
the midst of what's happening compared
to our easily trigger Abul president who
can't even be bothered to do any work at
this point never mind engage with the
problems that the country is dealing
with in a way that doesn't seem
patronizing or that will actually make
the problem worse I keep going back to
one of the thoughts I keep going back to
is the protest started because of anger
about treatment of black men by police
police using too much force police being
too brutal and what Donald Trump does is
say hey you know what the governors
aren't deploying enough law enforcement
force they're not doing enough shows of
strength I'm going to override them and
send in the military as if more law
enforcement force is the solution to
protests protesting about too much law
enforcement force being used it's
inconceivable there is it's hard to
think of someone more poorly suited to
lead at this point in time coronavirus
already proved it
the protests are only the latest example
and we've got five months we've got five
months and we are ultimately going to
decide what happens next we have a
voicemail number the number is two one
nine two david p you can call any time
of day now i want to say in advance this
is not a voicemail I can fully get on
board with and I've said before I don't
believe that shaming ant Abidin leftists
is the right thing to do from a moral
standpoint and I also don't think that
it's effective but I want to play for
you and
example of the frustration that is
starting to exist in some areas of the
left let me put it that way take a
listen why are we not hearing anything
let's see David I'm just gonna say it if
you're a progressive still trying to say
that Joe Biden is so on you may not vote
for your stupid look at the reaction to
these protests by this current president
and you're still debating on whether
you're going to vote for Joe Biden this
country probably won't survive another
four years under bunker boy I don't
understand how delusional
these progresses that still don't think
it's a good idea to vote for Joe Biden
are now do they really support the
minorities they claim to support by
sitting here still debating on whether
or not Joe Biden is a good choice after
looking at what bunker boy is doing now
these people are a disgrace well listen
the good news is I did a segment
yesterday a lot of mine ever Biden
followers have reached out in the last
24 48 72 hours and said this is the last
straw
and I now have to go for Joe Biden I
don't think it's productive to say that
the never Biden people are stupid and I
also don't think it's accurate I mean
some of them sure there's a lot of
stupid people in this country but a lot
of them aren't stupid they are using a
different barometer to evaluate the
situation and they are maybe coming to
different conclusions about what it
makes sense to do in November I disagree
with them I want to be vehemently clear
I don't know why I like saying it that
way vehemently clear we very much
disagree but saying they are stupid it's
arguably the same type of stuff that
helped get Trump elected in 2016 so I
understand the frustration I sympathize
with the frustration I based on my
progressive values don't see how anyone
could take an action that will allow
Trump to win now if you just want Trump
to win because you think he's better
than Biden maybe you came to that
conclusion or because you believe it
will teach
the DNC a lesson or you believe that you
know Bernie will like it or some like
listen if that's what you believe then I
just disagree with you but I don't know
how just evaluating the two candidates
at this point anybody could say I'm
gonna take an action either by voting or
by non voting that gets Donald Trump a
vote closer to getting reelected so I
won't be doing that I don't think
there's any advantage though to calling
people stupid and whatever else I
believe a lot of them I'm trying to take
an optimistic perspective a lot of these
folks who were 99% never Biden up until
five days ago or 97% or 92% they are
starting to come over I'm getting emails
from them and I believe by and large
they are going to do the right thing in
November we've got a great bonus show
for you today we're going to talk about
a mayor the mayor of Los Angeles
actually heeding the call from some of
the protesters and saying we're cutting
the police budget next year we're going
to cut police budget funding I also want
to talk about the Swedish coronavirus
response as we continue to get more
information about it and lastly because
of what's going on a lot of people are
depressed and anxious and as a result
the antidepressant zoloft and it's
generic version which have been around
for decades are in short supply because
of the degree to which they are now
being prescribed all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show don't
miss it become a member at join
pakman.com
you